Madam Prime Minister Mr.
Minister of the Armed Forces
Ladies and gentlemen Members of Parliament Ladies
and gentlemen Senators
Mr. Grand Chancellor Chief of the Defense Staff Ladies
and
gentlemen General officers
Officers Non-commissioned officers Petty officers
Soldiers  sailors aviator Jeanne
civil agency of the ministry of the armies
ladies and gentlemen
since 1790 and the first Fête de la
Fédération on July 14
is both a popular holiday and a
military parade
in these two aspects which are one and
the same is reflected in the  he unity of the nation and
the armies
in this time of cohesion
can be read in the spirit of unity which
must unite the French
and in the commitment of men and
women for the defense of their
fellow citizens until the ultimate sacrifice
if it  the need is expressed the greatness of the
values ​​which structure the armies and
which inherit our fear
their strength of soul their moral strength
these words that until here very
a year ago
they take on a very
particular acuity among you
between these  walls and under its windows which
were those of Clémenceau in 1917 and
of De Gaulle at the Liberation and we
history seems to be still contemplating
what he would see this evening at what I believe is enough to
reassure them
because the torch is taken up and the
presence  of our wounded
bereaved families of men to whom the mention
death for the service of the Republic
was awarded
testifies enough to the persistence of a
heroism which is never measured by
the yardstick of resignation and
habit
j  I have been by your side until now and
this explains our delay
alongside our wounded alongside the families
let's not forget any of those who have fallen
thank you Mr. Minister of the Armed Forces for
the organization of this evening which
allowed me to testify to them with the seriousness
and respect at the heart of the solidarity
that the nation owes them
all had not yet received the marks
of this recognition, however vital
we owed them this justice in the face of
the singularity of a commitment  who led them
to training for public service missions
to make the ultimate gift of their
existence
I also bow this evening with respect
before the sacrifice of Chief Warrant Officer
Guy Barcarès who
died for the service of the nation in
Guyana he  a few weeks ago in an
operation to fight against their mulching
a few weeks after the death of his
brother in arms the major of the gendarmerie
Arnaud blanc killed by a trafficker who has
since been apprehended and handed over to
justice
the gratitude of the nation is deep
towards them as towards you all
civilian and military personnel of the
armies and only the message that I
would like to convey this evening and share with
our international partners
represented here and alongside whom
the French armies defend our
security our common values
this gratitude implies actions
improvements  tangible in particular
the improvement in the care of the
injured
with a requirement of confidence I had
asked here a year ago for a
renewed effort in favor of this essential issue
the plan recently presented by the
Secretary of State replaces the injured  at the
center of everything in a concrete way with
the single form and the
digital house of the injured with the reinforcement
of the number of referents to support
the injured in Paris and in the provinces or
the opening of two new
houses to all before 2024
the foundations of this  vast project are
solid thanks to all those who have
real I would also like to thank the
project manager but this is only the
beginning
it is now a question of passing as you
say in driving and I have very very
attentive
this n  is only fair to watch over the
safety of those who watch over the
safety of French people every day on
all latitudes
the news of the conflicts is strong and
taking stock of what has been done
for a year beyond what  was
therefore presented for our wounded their
families I also wanted here more
broadly drawn to the cavalcade the assessment
of one July 13 the other of our action
the war in Ukraine testifies to
strategic rupture which is largely manifested
in aid to the  Africa from the bottom of the oceans
to the confines of space and
digital I know the efforts made
to deal with it we will continue
our aid to Ukraine the delivery of
scalp missiles announced
today testifies to this and what you have
accomplished is already
considerable the quality of the training
provided in France and Poland the
delivery of first-rate equipment
for our armies the French capability has
proposed breakthrough solutions such as
cats or solar defense were
an essential support for the bravery of the
Ukrainians,
I measure that this implies that this
implies efforts in your units and the
concern that a
war that lasts can generate
the chief of the army staff
advises me in his choices because there is
no question of weakening our defense
it is  material will be replenished and
this will not be done at the expense of
the ambition of the
military program the minister is watching over it but the
field begins as the
forces say the tempo of the war is changing the
rhythm of our support and I know the
mobilization of our units like
industrial mobilization I expect
a lot from it and the ability to respond to
this strategic emergency will
also determine the future place of our industry
because
the subject of the project on the
war economy that I have entrusted to you,
Minister  well there I salute the
results already obtained on the
production times of the César for example where the
first relocations are the way
to go but we are at a time
when we must
not do better simply we must do
more faster c  is different
we have to do what is necessary
for our Ukrainian friends a week is
an eternity supporting them has integrated
their time by accepting to take risks
by also accepting breaks in
rhythm and by making clear choices
that we have  started doing it to
get there
but you can see it clearly the return of the
war on European soil
led us to think differently to
react differently and I mean here
that France has also demonstrated the strength
of its model in a few days we  we knew how to
react each time we knew how to
open the flanks
and when it was necessary to deliver
and when it was necessary to open the way to
this determination we made it
understand the path for others
and that must be a source of pride for  our
armies for our industrialists but this
must reinforce our requirement because the
forces cold in the long term and
cannot be done
very clearly by subtracting
our commitment for ourselves in the
same way we were able to react in a
few days to deploy on  the
plan is from the Alliance
it is a choice that has
demonstrated the strength of the French model
to be national immediately in Romania
and to decide and deploy in a few days
it commands the admiration of some
but it reinforces the confidence of all
and today  France today in this
context in one year has greatly strengthened
its mobilization within
the Alliance in Romania in Estonia
but also in the air force we
have remained and appreciated since
last July 13 I also note with
satisfaction  that the armies have begun
transforming their presence
alongside our salt partners and more
broadly on the African continent
I announced it here a year ago it
was not easy and today it is
a
c  t is a major change in posture,
in short, a change in software which
testifies to greater listening,
greater intimacy with our
partners,
a redesigned footprint,
ambitious missions redefined with each of the
countries with which we cooperate, an
ever-asserted desire to  help this continent to
live in peace the presence of the
emblems of African military high schools
tomorrow on the Champs-Élysées is
for me the strongest incarnation of this, that
of France's loyalty to its
word and its commitments and to the
preparation of  the future but basically
what we have decided is to have a
less posed system and a
better thought out partnership where our partners express
their needs or say we meet them
and where we also know how to reinvest in
depth training
the  intimacy of respectful partnership and
long-term security for the
continent
finally I do not forget without
listing them all the sum of the operations carried out
for the security of the French the
continuation of the missions of fight against
terrorism in particular in Africa in the
Middle East l  affirmation of our
presence in common areas with,
for example, Operation Pegasus or the
Joan of Arc mission the relief
provided to our compatriots to our allies
and to the populations in particular
suddenly or the effectiveness of our armies
for our own nationals  but
also for the whole world,
the assistance provided to the
internal security forces in the fight
against the fires of the summer against the
trafficking their illegal mulching the
security of major events and the
strength and efficiency of our intelligence services was hailed
for our compatriots
as for all of our partners
who respect us and even recently
had to salute the quality of its
partnerships with French news
I know all that this also implies
in the shadows and I know all the
invisible without whom nothing  is not possible
as always you responded
quickly and present
so beyond this quick assessment I
also want to return to the Cap
no one can seriously dispute it
now
the effort made in terms of defense
for little more than 5 years was and more
than ever necessary
it is now reflected in the facts
and France, we should be
pleased about it, did not wait for the war in
Ukraine to initiate a massive effort, as
you know, we did not need
a wake-up call to be aware of the
need  to reinvest and engage and
face
new conflicts all over the
world,
but each passing day brings
additional confirmation of the
conclusions of our National
strategic review that I presented
last November in Toulon
I therefore want France overseas and
overseas  sea ​​power of balance and
training continue to have
armies of reference in Europe
more hardened more trained armies
which continue to modernize and
reinforce their support their stocks all
that makes the force and the coherence of
our defense
of the armies which  control new
areas of conflict a defense
based on renewed deterrence
and investing in major innovations
all of this was perfectly
illustrated during exercise 1 TER armed
multinationals Orient
we have therefore drawn up a
voluntarist military programming law
in the continuity of the previous one
which does not allow us and I say to myself here
with a lot of solids
because it is a strong commitment in
the context that we know for the
nation which will allow France
to have doubled its annual budget  of the
defense on the duration of these two programming laws
which country
can say that it has made such a commitment
over time and consistency and with the
credibility that we have since
the programming law passed
if it had never happened since
decades in Europe it will be the same
for the next
because yes
the programming law was first
prepared I would like here to
personally thank the Minister
the Senate
Major General of the Armed Forces General
Hocely I would like to greet this evening
and all of our armies of their leader
under their authority because in an
unprecedented way this programming law
a work a jersey if I may
say which I chaired through
several defense councils but which
has you all mobilized
and  I think it is an essential exercise
and it has made it possible to rethink
many things in depth it has also mobilized
and I also want to thank
the DGA the SGA the DGS for their
essential commitment in this
undertaking
your entire ministry but we  I
believe we proposed a
solid strategy this time and then debated
it is a guarantee of democracy and
here too I want to thank the Minister for his
personal action and all the
parliamentarians here present for
having beaten enrich this text
but also
I would say  for the whole nation
rested with thalice vitality the strength
of its debates and until the
last hours under the authority of the
Prime Minister who had
personally been able to find the
right decisions and the right compromises
in Mont-de-Marsan I had  fixed the axes
a modern coherent employment army
present in all fields all
credible spaces capable of winning the
war
I believe that the underlying strategy
was the right one that this law is the one
in our armies need and that
you have
in  the usual deadlines and after
the seizure of the controls which in the
Constitution provides for the promulgation of a
text which will then
require the commitment
of all of those whom I have cited
and in whom I have full confidence
we have  adopted a new course and I
want to say it this evening this one
obliges us all
with confidence with requirements so
your first duty will therefore be to properly
execute this military programming law
like the previous one but also
to bring it to life in a
naturally unstable strategic context
because our defense needs it but also
because it is the price of the trust
of our fellow citizens
for this
and I do not want to go back here on everything
that I have already extensively detailed in
Toulon and Mont-de-Marsan  of
strategy and the Cape I would
perhaps like to come back here at greater length
to the transformation of the minister the
ministry of the armed forces must be rethought
it is an imperative responsibility
the current model of organization and
operation was put in place in
a period  of continuous reduction in
defense spending
and it had been oriented towards this
end
the ministry was then adapted with the
intellectual discipline that we
know of it and I know the efforts the
treasures of ingenuity the sufferings
sometimes also that it took  cross
but this model proceeds from a logic that
made savings take precedence under the
guise of rationalization and
budgetary fragmentation
a logic that does not always or
not place war enough at the heart of these
organizations of its processes, but
today this model is no longer
first adapted because the choices that I have been bringing
to your head for six years are no longer
that I have sometimes had the opportunity to
recall it with a certain face here
even memory is good but
minds sometimes take time and
organizations even more to change
me I have confidence in our armies I have
made choices that have shown this
confidence and I had the immense honor
of having by my side
the great leader who gave me good advice
and  so the whole model
has to adapt and continue to change
the strategic context is radically
different the defense effort is
confirmed new forms of
conflictuality have developed
moreover young French people have a
different view of their commitment and therefore
it's all the
very concrete things that we need to do to build
loyalty, which is more than ever
a challenge to which we must respond with
a simplified daily operation
governed by more subsidiarity a
renewed effort to give them meaning in the
profession  to the missions entrusted a style of
command which is at the heart of this
battle and which was there also to be
reinforced and basically what makes the
strength of our armies in operation
it is necessary to know how to keep it in all
registers and in all places
Minister  you have perceived
this and perfectly measured this
need and I know that the scheme
has made proposals to you and that it
adores the reform of the
planning and operations management center has already been initiated
in this direction.
I therefore ask you to propose me some
ministry adaptation scenarios
by next summer paying
particular attention to the women of your
ministry men who are the center
of gravity of the transformation to come
a model geared towards the success of the
missions that I may be led to
to entrust to the armies to defend our
country our fellow citizens our interests our
values ​​this is the vocation of the ministry
this is the spirit and the heritage of those who
founded our Republic
and for this I want to give back the
levers of action to those who carry out the
missions  in operations as well as in the heart of the
territories
the organization should encourage
responsiveness facilitate the ability to
undertake leverage energies
focus the will on
carrying out the mission not on
avoiding internal difficulties
guarantee soldiers in the field
the means to accomplish  their tasks with
all the fluidity and performance
possible
basically there are four essentials for me
you must never lose
the strategic spirit it is decisive
and the purpose of the missions
you must keep everywhere the spirit of
responsibility
which is the one that irrigates  the good
command
it is necessary everywhere to impose the subsidiarity
that we know how to think in operation
and it is necessary to decline in each place of
life
everywhere we forget one of these four
cardinal values ​​we lose ourselves
in delays which become
bureaucratic in
disempowerment which discourages and
basically we lose what is the strength of
our armies every time they have to
act
and that it demonstrates at all times
our pride
in the women and men of
this ministry I hope that the
future model integrates the  expectations of the
youngest who enlist I care about
militarism I reminded you of it I no longer have
to demonstrate it
here for us in Europe everywhere we
would like to trivialize it and I will do so
until the last quarter of an hour
but this  militarism does not detract from the fact that
the women and men that you are
live in society
with aspirations of the reflections of
families and which come to shake up, it
must be said, some of our
organizations and therefore we must
indeed have a vision less
linear of the course take into account
the aspirations that must be heard in order to
recruit but also to retain we
will also need new
skills, we know that and when we
talk about cyber space threats,
we must be able to
recruit talents from the  skills that were
not necessarily those we
knew and profiles that
sometimes have other aspirations
we will need new paths
less poisoned more open also to
the administrations the
corporate communities and therefore the
social ladder must be reaffirmed  the
leadership style must continue to adapt
to future generations, we
must continue as we have
done to better take families into account,
which the family plan 2
will allow by strengthening the means, of course,
but also and above all the
relations with the  mothers the presidents
of departments and regions
to uphold the intimate ties between
our armies our territories we
will benefit from reducing the
Parisian concentration as well as asserting our
international presence with more
responsibilities at each level of
I also hope that the experience of the
armies in  the return to employment of
young people
at the SMV or SMA that the possibilities
opened up by universal national service
and the work undertaken around the
new reserves can continue to
weave a renewed link
between the armies and the nation
I believe that we have already demonstrated
in  many territories of the
Republic this model is a force which has
demonstrated its effectiveness what we are
going to do with the fnu will reinforce it
and many of the legitimate reflections which
today emerge because of what
we want to live deep in  what our
Republic has known for so many years
has partly an answer also in the
sense of remembering the commitment
it is not a question of confusing everything and neither there
also
of trivializing militarism or of
questioning our principles or of
returning  thus a professional weapon not at
all but to know who knows
new links as we have done from the SMV
to the SMMA through the first
stages of the SMU which allow us to
give meaning to the commitment and if
you want to take  my thought also to
give meaning to the duties that go
with the citizen
the strengthening of our
operational reserves also responds to these
imperatives the
battle of the workforce the
battle of the skills the link nation
armed and above all
will have our armies the course is set in the
long term  we will have one reservist for 2
soldiers
it is act 2 of
professionalization this choice was the
right one our now
professional army must be hardened it
must be based on a more
powerful reserve more numerous better equipped
better trained better integrated
it will be necessary  also ensure
harmonious taxation in
society for all soldiers and in
this regard I once again salute the
quality of the work of the hcocm the report
on officers which was
officially submitted to me this afternoon
points to important issues
positioning of the different
categories of soldiers between those
between them and in relation to the
corresponding civilian categories with
recidentify which are real in
terms of attractiveness of loyalty and
we bring lasting adapted answers
in terms of symbolic index material
but also of sense of
mission and organization
ladies and gentlemen
these weapons are strong coherence are the
guarantee for our country to exercise its
sovereignty to defend the wealth of
its territory its anchoring in Europe
and its ability to carry a voice listened to
and respected in the rest  of the world
this force requires us to reduce
our expenses because each of them
weakens our defense this is the whole
meaning of the agenda that we have been carrying for
six years the one that I defended at the
Sorbonne in the fall of 2017  a
European sovereignty including all
areas of humility to technology and
which we were able to convince Europe to
fully adopt in March 2022 at the
Versailles summit
this goes for our defense through a
real transformation of our
collective organization this goes through
the  innovation by our small and medium-sized
enterprises by our start-ups but also
by our large groups which
irrigates the major sectors of our
defense industries and also of
the dual industry through
demanding and constructive relations with these
industrialists and through a critical spirit if
dear to France
and I manage to thank all those
who contribute and who in
close connection with the DGA but with all of
our armies because the force is this
link allows us to move forward
to isolate our
planes with which we  we share a
destiny and many challenges because
together we are stronger
it is therefore in the European collective
that we must invest because it has proven itself
and I believe in our sovereignty will have
invested in our armies in
the industries but  I believe in a
stronger model in Europe and
strengthening within the Alliance
and I believe that it is sovereignty
complement each other because they are chosen there
is no good sovereignty if we
are dependent national sovereignty there
is no  there is no strong dress that can be
projected if there is not more
strategic autonomy and a real European pillar
within the Alliance to be respected
because tomorrow we will have better
protection for our neighborhood
and there  to defend the interoperability
that time offers us
this set does not imply
choices which would be
harmful no it implies to bring its
complementarities this is why
France is at the origin of
pragmatic initiative to reinforce precisely
this capacity of  having a defense dress
with
operational and industrial responses is
the case of the European
intervention initiative whose takuba force pile
illustrates the operational potential
and which we will have to continue to
strengthen I am thinking in this respect also of
the Franco-German squadron which will be
represented tomorrow at the parade and which
shows that European defense does
not consist in sewing blue badges
on your uniforms but in working with
all those who are ready to commit themselves
alongside us to act
European Union is not an
administrative mirage it is a multiplication
of the energy of those who are committed and
from the European defense front to
the European intervention initiative to
what takuba has enabled us to do that we
are going to multiply in  the
coming years for sure
and from what we have to suffer on the
industrial level it is essential because
in the plan in the industrial field
there too we are learning the lessons together
from covid as from Ukraine we are
reducing our expenses
we do not  we are not giving up our forces we are
pooling them the work on
the ASAP agreement to produce in Europe
the ammunition and missiles which
Ukraine lacks and which we also
need is a good
illustration of this we are open to
partnerships on a  pragmatic and
fair
it goes through the acceptance of
change with us as with our
partners
I think for example
oscaf
omgcs essential projects on which I
am committed from the summer of 2017 with what
time Chancellor Merkel who
reconfigures the balances which consolidates
the  future of French aeronautical and
land excellence and the balance
of which we ensure with confidence and high
standards with our partners
an independent France affirming its
European destiny it is also a France
faithful to its international alliances to
its historical strategic partners
or more  open to the world
as it is, as the recent
Paris summit shows, there is neither paradox
nor contradiction
in NATO,
which offers an
effective and almost exclusive interoperability framework for many
allies and our  role of framework nation
in operational commitments is in
this respect essential what we started
in Romania and which I mentioned is stalling this is
why we think the model
of our armies for today and
tomorrow can be a framework nation
for operations that we will have to
define because interoperability
allows it, but above all because we give ourselves
an autonomy that goes from intelligence to
the ability to deploy ourselves and to bring together
around us
the allies of the partners we
choose,
it is  a profound change is an
element of credibility for France
it is an element of confidence within
our alliance because I said with
great force we are today
lucky to have an
American administration which is at our side  war
returning to European soil, but our
imperious duty for us Europeans
within the Alliance and to be lucid
for the decades to come, it is
we who will have brought the burden of
our security and of the conflicts in our
neighborhood
because the  international geopolitics we will
impose it
refuse short-term blindness which
will lead us to
dreams and I say to myself here to all our
partners and therefore this investment
is essential this Europe of
defense which does not
remember in order to act it is the one which
protect tomorrow within this alliance
and respect each other
and we respect each other when we do not depend
but choose to work
together
Ladies and gentlemen on July 14 the
nation finds itself in the only unit
of the parade in the recklessness of the
popular balls  in the wonder of the
fireworks
and tomorrow we will be in this context
happy to welcome India as the guest
of honor of our challenge
it is a giant in the history of the world
which will have a determining role for our
future c  is also a
strategic partner and a country to love and I
said it I spoke a lot about our
European partners about our allies we
have been able to strengthen in recent years
with one in particular with the
United Arab Emirates with some other
essential new alliances and in particular within the
framework of indopathy which is an
essential strategy for the balance of the
planet for which France has a
strategic role because we have it among
the first to think of declining and that I am
taking the path  median that we are
pursuing and the good
India which is a key partner
the State visit of the Prime Minister
curses his participation alongside us
tomorrow in the parade with the presence of the
Indian armies says a lot about
our ability to dialogue to shine and
move forward together
the armies will show above
the Champs-Elysées in front of our
Indian friends the strength of this partnership
will also show what is modernized
to face both hands and that
this modernization passes through
moral forces consolidated
after the death of Jean Moulin 10  days
after the death of our dear Léon Gautier
the last of the commandos of June 6
the parade of 2023 invites us to
remember those who preceded us
to better take up the ideal torch
again at the Pantheon in Normandy
in Provence everywhere in France memory journey
will intensify until 2025 and you will
play a major role in it and we will have
assembled in the coming months this
journey celebrating these
important moments it will not be the only one because we
are one year away from the Olympic and
Paralympic Games in Paris and the  next year
the Olympic flame will light up our
parade between Vincennes and the nation
you will be involved in your
internal missions to help
secure its events to bring it to the
world some of you will
also take part in the competitions and
we are all behind it
because our armies have  all the fields
inspire us with respect and pride
they are the place of excellence and the
ideal
pegged to the body of the nation
and the celebration of July 14 is there to
remind us of
this this year as next year as
since 1790 the  parade on July 14
will remind us that some things are
worth committing to and
fighting for
that peace is not a comfort that we
buy with concessions
it is an ideal of justice
we must be  capable of defending
the France of July 14
is a
radiant sovereign France in Europe and in the world
capable of mastering its destiny
and the possibility of deciding on it
is France faithful
to the spirit of the companions
and then without
and it is a  France that you bring to
life
and in concluding I propose to you here I want to
repeat to you
my confidence and my pride
there is the strategy there is the course there are the
means we give there are
choices we make there  there are the partnerships
that we have, there are innovations that
we carry out,
but every morning and every evening there
are only the women and men
who launch themselves
and who, until the ultimate sacrifice,
rediscover the meaning of  this sacred link
between the army and the nation
is
this link
this commitment is a president
and each of our compatriots presents himself
to think about the intensity
the transcendence
the singularity
this is the one that must inspire us
every day it is  the one that commands
respect, the admiration that is
also necessary which must lead us
in each of our decisions
because the Republic as the nation
of a block
you have my confidence
which made me long
live the Republic long live France
[Applause]
evangelical and not
parents
whether to do
[Applause]